let's just say it's a woman that weighs
more than you she got the height she got
the reach and she got the weight and
she's like coming in and just is running
an option it's too late she already hit
you once and she's gonna do it again
what do you do it's okay I can run still
I grab her hands She's Got You cornered
damn it Ryan I'm fighting for my life my
actual life is in danger it's not my
pride it's my actual she's not gonna
kill you she just wants to beat you up
are there cameras out someone's going
live you won't die but there will be
visible marks are there cameras out how
do you know you're in the middle of a
fight you're gonna throw this
hypothetical I think I will do one of
those High School shoves a high school
show a high school show because what's
the high school Chef sometimes the high
school into a locker and then shut it
what's your high school sometimes a guy
square up against each other but it's
really just to kind of like Flex and not
to actually start the fight yeah that
but you know with your push she's gonna
fall down and Tumble right that's Geo's
push my push I might go like this and I
might fly back into the locker and it'll
close on me
you're out of the situation